we're taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's go to our next caller when we go
to the 905 area code I'm liking that our
caller caller from 905 tell us your name
where you're calling from and what's on
your mind today
hi there arm my name is David as well
I'm from a small town right outside a
well not really small but it's a town
right outside our Toronto called Ajax ok
um I've been a fan of yours for a while
actually the first video I saw was when
you were a debating of that professional
[ __ ] Jesse Lee Peterson well that's not
a word I use to be black but I'd call
him an uninformed the guy on the radio I
don't know that I'd go with the racial
slurs necessarily okay fair enough
um but uh I actually stumbled on that
video through our secular talk and I
watch all kinds of videos like T YT um
because American politics just interests
me in general um but I was gonna call
last week but I ended up having to go to
work cuz I saw some debates on T YT
between chenkin Ben and Hasan and some
other guy and I was just wondering if um
if you would ever go to Politico and
debate these right-wingers because I
feel like you would eviscerate them
listen I people have been asking me if
I'd go and do a political debate I would
I don't know if they if anybody wants me
there right I mean if I was invited I
would be glad to go I have not been
invited but I would have no problem
showing up there and talking about
whatever issue people want to talk about
as long as it's an issue I'm familiar
with right I mean it's it's not an issue
that's in my wheelhouse I probably
wouldn't be the best person but sure why
wouldn't I show up there what do you
think of the debate from the most recent
politican I mean it seems like a lot of
these guys they're not going to be taken
down because they just know their stuff
and it seems like it's not so much of a
debate as if it is just people
expressing their views as if they're in
their own eco change yeah I got a lot of
emails and David you might be able to
attest to this as well I got a lot of
emails from people saying hey been
destroyed jenk or Genk destroyed Ben or
Ana Kasparian destroyed an cult or vice
versa
I watched you know 10 or so minutes of
most of those big debates I found that
everybody came sort of prepare
to put their perspective out there I
might have missed like the big down
moments but I thought they were they
were pretty tamed by and large in terms
of a big wind yeah I was like a showcase
of of whose political ideals are better
but I feel like because you have an MBA
and you have that background in
economics you can throw all the moral
things out the way because everyone's
going to disagree on what's moral but
when it comes down to the economics I
feel like you could absolutely destroy a
guy who who doesn't even gone to
post-secondary education that's what I
was wrong who didn't go to
post-secondary education by the way arm
I proved I believe Bend doesn't have a
post-secondary education or the other
day that Hassan [ __ ] was armed isn't
ben shapiro a lawyer look if any have
ever lost isn't even it doesn't have a
JD yeah oh he does oh no I never mind
listen form there yeah all right listen
David I would go if asks to appear I
would appear David so thanks so much for
the call and it was sort of fun to watch
some of those debates although I just
didn't have time to watch that much of a
ton of them